sirens rang out over eastern ukraine
as the leaders of local pro-russian
governments told women and children to
flee and men to take up arms
i have to leave my home my apartment
because of all of this said this
russian-speaking resident
seven hundred thousand civilians are
reportedly headed to the border as the
self-proclaimed leader of the
separatists released a pre-recorded
video
a mass centralized evacuation of the
population to the russian federation has
been organized he claimed
evidence is growing that it may all be
part of a kremlin plan to manufacture a
pretext for invasion
a vehicle exploded in donetsk near a
pro-russian government building what the
u.s state department called a false flag
and ukrainian intelligence warned russia
was prepared to carry out terrorist
bombings that would then be blamed on
ukraine they will absolutely manufacture
an operation in order to create the
narrative that they want
to to gain the political outcomes that
they're looking for the prospects for
avoiding war seem increasingly dim
in washington u.s president joe biden
reiterated the dire consequences russia
would face after a call with prime
minister trudeau and other nato allies
russia has a choice between war and all
the suffering it will bring or diplomacy
that will make a future safer for
everyone adding to the tension russia
has massive nuclear drills planned for
the weekend that vladimir putin is set
to personally oversee
the assessment has shifted from
uncertainty to near certainty that
russia will launch some kind of action
as of this moment i'm convinced he's
made the decision we have reason to
believe that with avenues for putin to
back down increasingly limited and time
for diplomacy running out
that american certainty about a russian
invasion seems to be backed up by events
unfolding on the ground tonight russian
media reports that a major gas pipeline
in eastern ukraine has suffered some
sort of explosion and at the same time
jeff the u.s is all but certain that
russia is to blame for a series of cyber
attacks this week that took down
ukrainian banks and government websites
jackson proskow in washington tonight
thanks jackson